hello everyone and welcome to day three
of the championship showdown in the
chess960 edition or the chest 9 LX
Edition it's agaricus problem now with
the white pieces against Fabiano Caruana
and I didn't think I'd be doing any more
videos today but after seeing this game
I really didn't have a choice
so without further ado let's just check
it out so cuz para with the white pieces
opens with f4 with f5 by car wanna g3
with g6 so going symmetrical and now d3
which makes sense you wanna open up
these diagonals for additional export
the large barbershop also the Queen can
now come into the game Fabi of course is
doing the same he will play d6 at some
point and he will also free up his queen
Knight 8b 6
and now c4 by Kasparov with d6 preparing
a five-night to see to end now he 5s
plan with a pawn captures Bishop
captures and now Queen to a5 so just
bringing that Queen out very early into
the game
something Kasparov has been doing quite
a lot in these chess960 games and now
Queen to a4 karana offers a queen trade
straight away Kasparov continues
development with Knight the b3 attacking
the sorry defending the Queen and a5
also the queen is guarding the pony too
so it's not a problem
c6 and the now comes Bishop to d4
Kasparov offers the trade of bishops and
now far betrayed twins with Queen
captures her Queen captures on a
five-night captures an a5 and now Knight
to e7 Caruana
also continues development he's
preparing King to c7 he wants to connect
his rooks
with King 32 because part of also
connects rooks and gets the King to a
nice an icer second square more
centralized King to c7 Fabi also
connects rooks and now before Kasparov
grabs more space on the Queen side and
here f4 by Caruana and this is where the
fun really starts
Kasparov pushes c5 attacking the knight
with 937 now putting pressure on the
pawn on c5 and here after after a fairly
long think has percolated G captures on
f4 and now he's asking Corona do you
want to play rook
actors on f4 and then we're just gonna
trade the bishop captures pawn captures
rook captures pawn captures where the
material and the board is equal or do
you wanna try and grab a pawn with
Bishop captures an f4 and here corona
did give it some thought and he played
Bishop captures on f4 but Kasparov
prepared a very nice exchange sacrifice
rook captures on f4 rook captures and
now C captures and v6 with Czech opening
up a discovery against DA a 7-point King
to d6 you have to capture as your knight
on e7 is also under attack but shall
capture some a7 attacking the rook rook
back to a8 and now push her back to e3
attacking the f4 rook we have rook F the
F 8 and here casparo should go into
Knight capture son b7 this will weaken
the c6 pawn for example Knight captures
with check King c7 King c7 9 8 5 and
loud the Knight attacks the c6 pawn the
bishop attacks the c6 pawn this rock can
come to seize to also join the party
attacking the c6 pawn but even though
this is the strongest move recommended
by the engine Kasparov plays the
strongest human move Bishop to h6 and
here was the first time where Fabi
really started to spend time in pretty
much all the games that I've seen so far
here probably spent really a lot of time
and it's not easy to deal with this
position you have to deal with Knight
captures and b6 check and also your rook
is hanging there on f8 but the problem
is you have to play b6 here this is the
strongest continuation for Caruana i
just give up the rook Bishop captures
rook captures and now Knight Returns to
b3 and here you have to play this
position where Casper is up upon and
well karana just doesn't want to do this
and after this Bishop takes 6 move he
didn't find a point to b6
he played rook to e8 and now Casper goes
for it Knight captures on b7 with check
King to c7 and now he doesn't retreat
and go for the attack against the c6
pawn like we've discussed but rather b5
liked all Kasparov is a natural-born
born killer and he you know he just has
to go forward all the time
and here karana finds Luke 2:8 for it's
the
good move in the position you're
preventing Bishop to f4 check which
would really put a lot of problems yeah
you create a lot of problems for black
or if you don't play if you play
something like King captures and b7
which of course is the obvious move then
you get pawn captures with check it's
now a protected pawn the rook opens up a
discovery King c8 for example and now
pawn captures with check also you're
gonna lose the rook on a 8 and here
karana would just fall apart so rook
play for really strong move but now
night the be for now Kasparov again
starts complicating things
and again if King captures on b7 here
this is the strongest move but it's a
hard to decide on this move for example
kink actress be captures on c6 with
check King to c8 and now see captors and
b7 with check King captures and now the
point is that there is no Bishop to c6
checked I grab any of the rooks because
the knight guards it and if you attack
the knight here just looked the c8 and
now the rook also guards the c6 square
so there are no checks and this is a
fine for black but Bobby also started
wasting time here and he didn't find
King capture some b7 Bobby Flay played
Knight to d5 and now Kasparov finds the
absolute best continuation be captures
on c6 and here again I Kasparov asks do
you want to win a piece here for example
but the problem is if you play Knight
captures on before you get C captures on
d7 and now you can't capture the pawn
with the King because of 95 check picks
up the rook so that's not possible you
have to play rook after Sunday to with
check King to c3 and now either just
lost with black your rupees under attack
your knight is under attack here you
could continue playing this King capture
some b7 rook capture some before and now
roof for example
characters on e - but still it's it's
not all that possible your King is just
in the center of the board amongst all
of Kasparov species you're just gonna
attack it and eventually you're going to
either fork something or SKU or
something or it is just not gonna work
for example 95 check
c8 bush of the b7 check also possible
King c7 now you bring the bishop into
the game but should be for f4 check pink
the DNR gonna go look the d8 check
really not a lot of scores for the Black
team
kingi 8th now Bishop the c6 check King
f7 and I'll finally Bishop d5 check will
win the rook on a - well the exchange at
least so after this I moved like a
sparrow be captures on c6 Khurana finds
the strongest reply rook captures on b4
and okc capture sun b7 with king
captures on b7 and not night
the c5 check King to b6 attacking the
knight and now rook captures on b4 with
Knight captures and before and now
Knight to e4 with check King to e6 and
now
Kasparov can decide where he wants to
play a three attack the knight push a
four but Kasparov prefers Knight to c3
just defending the pawn and asking Fabi
what what does he want to do karana
played f5 King at five he wants to play
g5 and trap Kasparov the bishop on e6
sokka's poor pushes a three now kicks
away the night and night has to go to a
six as the light square bishop slices
over the lights worse
and here comes power really started
wasting time he had a little over a
minute here and he spent all of his time
he brought his time down to seven
seconds and okay you do have the delay
but it's seven seconds it's really hard
to play here you you should play d4 and
start pushing your points E 4 D 5 and so
on but here comes power played Bishop to
c6 attacks the rook
he wants to go Bishop here at the to
check the black king but here but with 7
seconds on the clock it's very difficult
Ruby 8 he wants to go for Ruby to check
and start you know picking up pawns but
shortly 7 check but now Fabi has Bishop
to e6 he Fabi really wants to trade off
at least one of the bishops because
playing against the bishop pair in an
open board it's just very hard Eve or
check by Kasparov King to f6 and now
Casper has the trade Bishop captures
team captures and Bishop the f4 you
don't want to allow the rook check picks
up the pawn
Fabi still goes for
check with King to e3 and now rook to b3
now you're attacking the knight and the
pawn here King to d2 also possible was
King to d4 and king c4 and then you
start pushing your pawn but cuz part of
prefers the defense from behind with
rook captures on a three and now d4
finally as part of still with seven
seconds on the clock playing wood on the
delay Knights the b4 by Fabi and now d5
check with King to d7 and here Kasparov
plays d5 it's natural you're very long
on time you want to start pushing those
two connected passed pawns but this
doesn't really work here Fabi had a a
trick both of them missed it
he had rook captures on c3 which just
leaves Kasparov completely busted after
you capture you just lose the pawn with
check next King before you capture the
bishop and now Bobby's just up a knight
but both of them missed it I thought we
played rook to a5 and now cuz peril just
continues pushing his passed pawns ecigs
would check in to e 7 and now bush of
the c7 attacking the rook and well now
preparing to bring the King into the
game rook the a6 and now King III corona
brings the rook back rook to a3
attacking the knight and now King before
but now the same idea doesn't work
rather it does work it's
Coronas best move he should play rook
captures and c3 here although now you
first get d6 check you don't want it to
leave the bishop and c7 defenseless and
now after King captures on e6 you're
gonna capture here and this end game is
a draw but after King cap king before
corona played night the see to check he
wants to drive away Kasparov King so he
can win the night here but you're
welcome to feel feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the move
Kasparov played which wins the game for
white well I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent sacrificer of pieces to win
winning end games and for those who just
wanna enjoy the show King 'if v is the
winning move here and now d6 d7 and d8
is coming you don't really care about
your knight on c3 Khurana
so very long time he decided to capture
it it is the best move rook captures on
c3 and now v6 with Czech king the f8 and
now d7 Casper o is now ready to promote
his pawn into a queen this is completely
winning for white but Khurana plays
rooked III check we have King to f6 but
the problem is Kasparov played King to
f6 and at the moment he hit the clock he
saw that the clock was already on zero
seconds and it was in this position that
Garry Kasparov lost the game as he ran
out of time which is one of the reasons
why I decided to leave the code above
the board okay it's not about I mean but
it is you know our first part is about
the age but the time is the most
powerful opponent and none of us can be
here even though Kasparov has a
completely winning position he ran out
of time but it is a tricky position
because Kerwin actually wanted as part
of to go to f4 to still try and create
complications for example if the game
continued we would see rook f3 King back
t5 Brooke III and now for example King F
for Coronas idea was rook to f3 check
King captures Knight d4 check King e4
and now you capture on e6 now Kasparov
promotes the pond to a queen you
eliminate the Queen and you play this
position which is of course completely
winning for white but with as part of
being so down on the clock karana had to
look for his chances there so really a
tough break for the former world
champion again completely outplayed the
Khurrana in the rapid section he didn't
miss that route capture since e3 idea
but he had very few seconds on the clock
and Khurana missed it is also just
insane game really just it was really
awesome watching it live so if you if
you have time do check out the entire
footage life I'm sure it will be
available online so you know really
really just an awesome game so I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
save Amazon forest and Steve Troy
closed-source Raleigh for introduced to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
probably with a few
games from this wonderful event and then
we are continuing with the Capablanca
saga and checking up on your suggestions
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day